all right one thing that i found on
twitter last night was a tweet from espn
running a link to the espn.com website
with
a conversation between mike greenberg
and roger goodell greenberg spoke to all
of the sports commissioners and the
biggest news in the discussion between
greenberg and goodell came from
goodell's comments about colin
kaepernick a guy that goodell did not
mention in that video that first
surfaced 11 days ago here is goodell
talking to mike greenberger of espn
about colin kaepernick
if he wants to resume his career
in the nfl
that obviously is going to take a team
to make that decision but i welcome that
support the club making that decision
and encourage them to do that um if his
efforts are not on the field but and
continuing to work in this space
uh we welcome to that to that table and
and to be able to help us and guide us
and help us make better decisions about
the kinds of things that need to be done
in communities
we have invited them in before and we
want to make sure that everybody's
welcome at that table
and trying to help us deal with some
very complex difficult issues that have
been around unfortunately for a long
time
but i hope we're at a point now where
everybody's committed to making
long-term sustainable change
all right that's good dell specifically
in response to the question of colin
kaepernick's status and he said he would
encourage a team to sign him look i i've
been saying this all along
if he really wanted a team to sign colin
kaepernick it would happen quickly
things like this happen things happen
behind the scenes deals get done now
look they would have to maybe give
something up they'd maybe have to give a
super bowl to a city maybe have to close
the deal that way give a draft to a city
come up with something else you know in
a sports league
every team always wants something
there's always something that the league
office can
give out
on a discretionary basis so
the teams try to get in position for
things they want okay you want something
we want something and the question is
whether to what extent the commissioner
is willing to use the employment of
colin kaepernick as a bargaining chip in
this
tit-for-tat quid pro quo stuff that
happens all the time between league
offices and the teams and if they really
wanted to get it done they get it done
it's a phone call or two maybe three you
get it done you find a team to take him
and people would be surprised to know
that's the way the sausage is made well
that's the way the sausage is made so
look it's one thing to answer a question
that you're asked directly and what else
is he gonna say if you really want him
back in the nfl there's a way to get him
back in the nfl well yeah i agree with
you mike and that's why first off you're
awesome you've been banging the drum
about this the whole time and you know i
actually
i i i refer back to something you you
kind of talked about this weekend i
think it was on pro footballtalk.com
mike where i just found it interesting
and i thought you know nonetheless like
to your point you would think the nfl
could get on a group phone call with all
the owners and say hey we gotta figure
out where we're gonna get colin
kaepernick you know this is good for the
players in our league it's good for our
league in general it's good for society
and it's certainly good for the
african-american society and culture and
everything that's going on in the world
right now so it's a good move but what
i'm amazed about and bringing it back to
what i read over the weekend i think it
was the weekend mike damn i read so many
articles and stuff now i can't even
remember you know
why doesn't anybody want to be branch
ricky that's that's what i don't get
doesn't somebody like you know want to
be that guy that beacon of hey
i made the right move even though
society was scared to do this and i've
done it and you go into the laurels of
history forever just like branch ricky
did and they made a movie about him and
you know they made him to look to be a
good guy and whatever else i just would
think from that standpoint let alone
mike like you've said a million times
the business standpoint i think there's
going to be a lot of positives there too
you know especially to teams that okay
are in cities that we feel like a fan
base uh could could wrap their heads and
and around the colin kaepernick signing
maybe more than others i would think it
would be good for business so i'm just
surprised that nfl owner hasn't kind of
dabbled in this by themselves already
without needing the league push or guys
like us pushing them to do it
immediately colin kaepernick would have
the top selling jersey in the nfl in his
new team's colors and logos immediately
that team would have a national
following immediately the coach the
owner the gm or some combination of the
three would be hailed as somebody who
would be like a modern-day branch ricky
and obviously the two situations are
different branch ricky is the general
manager was of the brooklyn dodgers who
broke the color barrier in baseball in
1947 by signing jackie robinson but this
is the similar idea it's a big moment
figure right and who's going to rise
above it who's going to say to that
percentage of the fan base however big
or small it may be and i think it's
smaller than the nfl realizes and also
you're taking on the president if you
embrace colin kaepernick who's going to
be the one to do that and say hey
if you don't like it
that's your problem kind of the baker
mayfield attitude we read yesterday
baker mayfield's instagram message to
anyone that would have an issue with his
decision to kneel during the national
anthem he said if i lose fans over it i
don't care and i think the nfl needs to
get to the point where they just don't
care they're going to do the right thing
so i frankly
don't put a lot of stock
in what roger goodell said to espn from
the standpoint of it opening some door
or breaking some barrier to me when i
hear the words when i see the delivery i
just think he answered the question the
only way he could
if he wants him back in the nfl
there's an easy way to make it happen
and we mentioned the president that that
is one of the things that may be keeping
a team from signing colin kaepernick
roger goodell also told mike greenberg
the nfl will continue to focus on our
work despite any criticism from the
president but i still feel like at some
level there is a hesitation
to engage the president in a full-blown
back and forth constant battle
on social media or elsewhere and i just
want to see the league get to the point
where they just don't care and the best
way to show you don't care is to get
colin kaepernick on a team
well yeah it is and and to support the
players for kneeling for the anthem if
that's what they decide to do as far as
their form of peaceful protest whatever
that may be but yeah the nfl needs to
support that um and i i mean again yeah
you know donald trump he's gonna
continue the president's gonna continue
to stick his nose into this situation we
know that you know he's he's obviously
passionate about it do i think he's
wrong about his feelings and and why
it's done of course i do i mean it's
really wrong but i do think the nfl's
best course of action at this point is
to just stay steadfast and go forward
with what we're doing right now we've
seen more progress and it feels like the
nfl and the important decision makers
have opened their eyes more here
recently than ever before and i think
you know as we've talked about there's
real momentum not only in our country
but in the nfl to get things changed
we've never seen it kind of move this
much in this short of a time and i just
think with this one yes it does the nfl
no good to get in a little fight or a
tit-for-tat fight with you know the
president none of that ignore it move on
we feel as the nfl we're doing the right
thing for society for our players and um
sorry mr president we disagree with you
and that's all there has to be said
about the situation
yeah i mean this fear that still seems
to be paralyzing the nfl when it comes
to taking on the president when it comes
to taking on the percentage of the fan
base that still insists that kneeling
during the national anthem automatically
constitutes disrespect of the flag the
military the the country no matter how
many different people come out and say
that's really not what it is they got to
get past that fear and whether it's
in making clear public statements
by owners not the commissioner that
there is support for protests during the
anthem by signing colin kaepernick by
changing the washington name these are
the things that would send the loudest
clearest message that the events of the
past 22 days the cumulative events from
the george floyd murder up to the rachar
brooks murder and all the protests and
the awakening and the piercing of our
bubble that this has caused and the
commitment to change and so many people
now involved in speaking out and finding
ways to assist
to show that the nfl truly gets it and
truly has had the same awakening the
rest of the country has had most of the
rest of the country has had those are
the things that need to happen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports